nostalgia street rods the sponsors of
this next segment has an incredible
collection of hot rods and muscle cars
and this weekend you can see it for free
with their classic car show who else but
jc fernandez would be covering this he
stopped by
[Music]
this is a 1932 ford roadster one of the
first two doors with a v8 it is pure
power but this car it's just the tip of
the iceberg when it comes to the car
collection inside nostalgia street rods
what do you say we go inside and
take a look
sherry i have to ask last time i was
here i feel like you have more cars how
many cars are in the collection oh about
150 that you can see wow so how did this
whole thing start well my parents
started collecting six for 65 years they
collected together and i built the
museum so that we could keep history
alive and show people what they thought
and love to collect and your family is
such a fabric of las vegas and coming up
with your car show this is a chance for
everyone to come inside and see this
collection for free what else is
happening at the car show so it's
november 6. i'm eight to four and
there's going to be food vendors here
there's going to be raffles there's
going to be a dj there's going to be a
live band um and who does it benefit um
it benefits the speedway children's
charity which is a great organization
yes and the great thing is vaughn hot
road is going to be here come on hot rod
yeah if you know cars you know vaughn
hot rod he's going to be here he is
going to be here he's our special guest
tell me about these two right here this
yellow one what's this so this is a 48
prefix it's a drag car and of course you
know it runs on the quarter mile
that is so cool i love how that engine
is just like a muscle popping out of the
hood of the car right right and to the
other side what's this one here this is
a 41 willys with a 383 small block in it
the paint job on this one it's like a
cherry coca-cola yes it's beautiful and
someone told me you have a chevy room i
do i am so excited because i don't think
you've ever seen it i see it yeah and
i'd love you to meet dominique all right
let's go to the chevy room all right
[Music]
there's just so many cars in this
collection
what is this check out our zamboni ice
machine it's got a 454 and it can really
you know cut some ice why not go nights
go go knights go you can clean the ice
very fast with that big of an edge oh my
goodness yes you can this is definitely
a room full of chevys dominique how's it
going i'm good how are you jc great tell
me about this one so we've got this
really nice 57
chevy convertible right here i love it
and then this purple one this beautiful
purple one's actually our 56 chevy and
what is your favorite part what are you
looking forward to most with the car
show coming up i'm actually looking
forward to we have the raffle going on
um we're also still taking registrations
the day of the show so you don't
necessarily have to register beforehand
we'll be here the day of taking
registrations that's great and then tell
me about this chevy this one here is
actually my favorite it's our 57 chevy
it is all original and it actually is
low mileage if you want to go take a
look at that 30 miles 44 miles 44
original miles that's insane yeah hey jc
by the way i think sherry's outside
she's got one more thing she wants you
to see all right let's go sherry you got
big rigs how many of these trucks do you
guys have 14 and a couple fire trucks
would it be on display at the car show
they will be and who's the benefit again
speedway children's charity november 6th
come out and enjoy the fine can i get
the keys to this thing
all right i don't proper license but
we're in a parking lot let's go
[Music]
that's not going to end well
but
in any case goldstrom's classic car show
is on nostalgia or nostalgia street rods
i should say is located at 5375 cameron
street frame of reference that's not too
far away from the orleans casino if you
want more information you can call that
phone number
702-876-3652 or go to
nostalgia's tree
nostalgia okay on the prompter it was
separated i got it now nostalgia
streetrods.com mercedes